hot on the heels of oculus rift HTC and
valve have just upped the ante with five
it's more expensive at $800 compared to
rifts $600 but for good reason
five comes with a pair of
custom-designed steamvr controllers and
two hefty base stations that allow
software to track your movement over a
maximum area of 15 square feet five
strongest selling point is how it
marries freedom of movement and
intuitive controls with a capable
headset but these premium features come
with considerable requirements to
experience what it's like to walk around
in VR with vive you need a minimum
unobstructed area of six and a half by
five feet in a way to provide power to
both of Ives base stations while Vives
controllers are valuable and a factor in
the higher cost of vive the ability to
partake in room-scale experiences is an
equally important selling factor and one
that will prove difficult to implement
for some users no matter how you choose
to use vive the headset is the most
critical part of the experience
it's bundle of four cables seemed
noticeably obtrusive when you're
stationary but even more so when moving
around a room though I did get better at
blindly managing them the more I used
five I still stumbled on them over
occasion five can't match rift when it
comes to comfort and when you consider
that rift has built-in easily adjustable
headphones it's hands down the most
user-friendly of the two from a
technical standpoint the displays and
rift and vibe are practically identical
they both have an LED screen with a
refresh rate of 90 Hertz and offer a
resolution of 1080 by 1200 for each eye
as with rift I found vibes displayed to
be adequate though not impressive the
low latency and high refresh rate of the
displays allow you to experience VR
without the threat of simulation
sickness due to hardware deficiencies
but you will notice that displays pixels
every time you put vibe on its base
stations and controllers make the
physical setup process a bit complicated
but the tutorial in steamvr guides you
through the procedures step-by-step and
confirms that everything is working as
intended and once you have everything up
and running steamvr walks you through a
demo that teaches you the ins and outs
of the controller and introduces you to
the chaperone steamvr s term for the
virtual walls of projects into VR when
you get close to the real-world boundary
of your VR play space the chaperone
feature makes sure that you don't
inadvertently run or walk into walls a
tasket accomplishes effectively but if
you're working with the minimum amount
of space which is six and a half by five
feet prepare to see wireframe boundaries
appear frequently as you move about you
navigate steamvr using the controllers
as you would a lay
Poynter more or less in the laser from
your virtual controller at an item on
screen and pull the trigger to select it
your UI in VR is for more than picking
what games to play you can also swap
your view to interact the steam proper
or to navigate your PCs desktop of
course if you're considering vive in the
first place it's because you want to
play games in VR first and foremost
there are a lot of games available to
provide at launch almost too many
considering how many of them are small
canned experiences but some games
straddle the line such as job simulator
2050 you work in a comically depressing
office space run by robots among a
handful of other work-related scenarios
where you're ordered to perform menial
tasks it sounds dreadful
but it's actually quite enjoyable thanks
to good writing and a large variety of
objects to interact with it's not the
sort of game you'd be desperate to play
outside of VR but vive embeds you in the
experience in a way that reshapes your
connection to the virtual world that
statement applies across the board when
referring to vibes room-scale supported
games while the quality of the game is
very greatly they all inherently deliver
an impressive experience by allowing you
to walk around and by treating your
controllers as extension of your hands
to interact with objects for the moment
vibe offers the most feature-rich vr
experience there is if you list it
features it has compared to rift there
will only be a few differences but vibes
few advantages make a big difference in
practice to go with rift is to wade in
the waters of V are choosing vive is
like jumping into the deep end it's not
the easiest suite of hardware to set up
nor is it as refined as rift but vibe
delivers the most advanced VR experience
to date for people who cannot wait who
are willing to go the extra mile v is
the only way to experience today's most
advanced VR technology from the comfort
of home
you